lunch money well while she's trying to
get rich the rest of us is trying to get
our lunch money right polina what are
the topics
today
all right well i was ready with the
trillionaire energy unlike you with the
you you only got like multi-millionaire
energy today
go ahead i got the trillionaire energy
okay go ahead speaking of uh
trillionaire energy teg giants lost more
than one trillion in value in the last
three trading days you see what i did
there i did that's crazy what is going
on it's a bloodbath out there guys
carnage carnage everywhere there's three
markets that i think people should be
paying attention to one is all the
public stocks two is crypto three is the
private markets if you think of the big
large public companies they're all
bleeding and it ain't going to stop
anytime soon the fed has in control the
fed is in control they are going to
continue to increase interest rates
they're not talking about 50 basis
points at a time they have pulled their
bid out of the market and they are going
to push asset prices down and they are
going to punish you they're going to
punish the average pensioner and they're
going to punish anyone that is in
financial markets until they get
inflation under control my guess is that
this is going to happen much quicker
than they believe
and they will cool off by the end of the
year and maybe even we get a little rate
cut again that's my little uh what do
they call it uh
contrarian no contrarian view everyone
thinks they're going to keep hiking
rates a couple of people think they're
contractors like oh maybe they won't
hike as much no i'm going the opposite
i'm saying we're going to get one rate
hike again maybe 70 confidence i reserve
the right to change my mind but at the
moment seventy percent confidence it's a
lot of disclaimers of course it is
listen seventy percent confidence is all
probabilities seventy percent
probability that before the end of the
year we get one rate cut
if as we go they start changing the way
that they're talking about this stuff
then maybe my confidence will increase
or decrease i'll keep you updated
whoever said this segment is the worst
part of the show
well they're a loser
no they're not losers no they are no be
kind to your friends um all right
janet yellen
says that the financial system is
working well despite the potential for
continued volatility
well to be fair that's probably true
[Applause]
what in the financial system is not
working uh in terms of uh what they're
attempting to do well the fact that
they're blaming russia and china's
lockdowns for inflation yeah but that to
me to me my view my view is that that's
not the financial system not performing
what that ends up being is more about
this idea of uh the way that they're
describing it who they're laying blame
on is obviously stupid everyone knows
it's stupid no one believes it nobody
thinks that vladimir putin created a gas
hike nobody zero people believe that and
so ultimately what ends up occurring is
that they may uh lay the blame there but
just because they lay the blame there
doesn't mean that the financial system
isn't working so in what way is the
financial system working even though
they like kind of manufactured go to
2008-2009
banks failed and literally went bankrupt
there was a a financial crisis and the
banks were brought to their knees that
was a financial system with systemic
risk because literally if they didn't
step in if they didn't do certain things
some of those more of the banks would
have went out of business it would have
been really bad at bloodbath now what's
happening is yeah asset prices are going
down but it's actually a system that is
operating the way it is designed to
operate now we may disagree with why
they're doing it or even how they get to
that being the thing that they should do
but ultimately their whole thing is the
federal reserve is in control they
should be able to expand or contract the
monetary supply they should be able to
manipulate interest rates in response to
the macro environment so that it creates
an ability for humans to now have
control over an economy i personally
disagree that that is the best strategy
but that is the way that the system is
designed today and so what they are
doing is they are expanding and
contracting the monetary supply they're
increasing and decreasing interest rates
and they are they're playing gepetto
that's what they're doing they're like
you know up there and geppetto's dancing
here that's exactly what the uh federal
reserve is doing they're playing gepetto
in markets they say ooh grow grow grow
grow then say
come back down come back down
don't fight the fed number one rule in
investing right now
don't fight the fight don't fight the
fed just go with the flow of the fed the
fed literally this was the trade over
the last two years
buy assets when they said we're coming
into the market if the fed comes in the
market you go in the market
when the fed says we getting out the
market you get out the market guess what
news flash if the fed says hmm we
changed our mind we're getting back in
the market
probably should listen and say i'm just
going to do what the fed's going to do
it's kind of like when i ask an investor
they're like oh there's this great
company oh you should really look at it
my first question is are you investing
if you're in i'm interested if you're
sending me a deal and you're not
investing probably not interesting well
but it might be in your wheelhouse not
in theirs
ain't nobody got a wheelhouse if it's a
good deal
i don't care if you invest in biotech
if you get the chance to invest in mark
zuckerberg right you should invest do
you do do investors really send you
deals that they don't invest in
yeah
and then i ask them are you investing in
that and they call some nonsense answer
well you know i have a savings account
checking account and then savings
account and checking like whatever and
so i hit him with
nah um i don't even need to talk to the
founder if you're not if you don't think
it's good enough for your money then it
ain't good enough for my money and
definitely not good enough for my money
exactly perfect okay
andy so so while all of this is
happening guess what's happening in the
i guess private
art markets andy warhol
i can't say it warhol
wait how do you say andy warhol warhol i
don't even know how you say that's how i
say it i know there's certain words in
the english language i just don't even
try that's one of them
andy's andy's 1964 portrait of marilyn
monroe sold
for god i can't speak today 195 million
at christie's monday night that is the
painting how did i not get it you know i
have a maryland painting that's 195
million dollars yeah i'll be an artist
listen i'm about to be an artist you can
make 195 million dollars you cannot
paint that that looks like someone did
it on photoshop what you mean
that literally looks like someone
photoshop that hair does not look real
what about the nfts are you going to say
this is number come on listen
by the way nobody is compl is comparing
nfts to physical art all i'm saying is
that uh that's insane and it's more
about the story than the art that piece
right there sold for 195 million dollars
because 194 million and 900 uh 900 000
worth yeah is because andy warhol's name
on it and 100k because of what it looks
like an orange version recently sold to
hedge fund billionaire ken griffin for
over 200 million and they said it's the
mount everest of its era everyone in the
world when these paintings were made
knew the story of marilyn monroe the
epic loss and the epic achievement andy
himself was beginning to become an icon
and he did so it's two icons and their
height you know that's a good question
is andy dead he is
dead unfortunately dead rest in peace uh
but he he he is uh what we would call a
uh uh he's running a scam
he's not running anything he is not
here with him he sold a piece of canvas
for 200 million dollars he told a story
around it no not him no but i'm just
saying like he he created something and
it grew to 200 million dollars like
there's a whole scam going on that's not
a scam that's called capitalism
can i get the meme with the thing yeah
you're not wrong that was that actually
was that was there was like one thing
you could have said there that i'd be
like yeah yeah you're not wrong uh that
was what you could have said that was
pretty good that's actually very good
i'm impressed well thank you you you i'm
actually hilarious you don't think let's
keep going let's keep hilarious let's
keep going so
all right so this is really interesting
i didn't know that this was happening
facebook's meta store or sorry
facebook's meta or meta that used to be
facebook is opening a physical store did
you know this yes i did oh my god did we
not talk about this it's a 15 1 550
square foot space and it's getting
increasingly serious about creating
consumer hardware is this are they
trying to be apple is that what's
happening there's definitely a sense of
that but also there's a ton of um
uh companies that are doing stuff like
this so amazon's going into physical
stores like amazon has bookstores now
the irony of like they were created
online bookstore to disrupt physical
bookstores and now have become a
physical bookstore again uh is hilarious
also amazon oh we're gonna have a
digital grocery offering now they have
physical uh grocery offerings right same
thing with facebook is we're gonna be
this digital social network digital
products now they have a physical
product store uh and so ultimately
you're gonna see this over and over
again where at some point you just
realize like you still need physical
space and especially if you're selling a
hardware device it may be good
to have an ability for people to try it
before they buy it
what do you think mall space like
abandoned mall spaces will be used for
in the future i think people should go
buy them and turn them into uh
apartments
like you this is uh for the longest time
i've seen people try to do this as well
i think it's a great idea i haven't seen
anyone yet that's like nailed it but uh
i know of multiple companies that want
to go buy malls yeah and then what they
want to do is they want to take like the
department stores yeah at the ends
turn those into high-rise apartments and
then the middle section
uh of the mall turn that into like a
living space with restaurants and all
like and so basically you create like a
little city yeah vertical city but a
city yeah and then around the outside
they usually have tons and tons of uh
space
and so you can create parks and like all
you know i mean you could like create
like a whole living environment uh at
the malls it's expensive but uh
definitely think it's possible yeah all
right that's interesting well we're
flying through these
okay i'll take some questions get your
questions into the chat room are we
gonna do live questions maybe
okay so this is hilarious
three armed kenyan wildlife officers
must have been on high alert as they
cautiously approached a homestead
following reports that a stray lion had
been cited in the area
please show the stray lion
turned out to be a bag
that's a bag yeah
isn't that amazing so they mistook
mistake
or a bag for a real lion where is this
in kenya come on isn't that great
come on they were look at this bag it's
amazing i expect that to happen it's a
false alarm i expect that to happen
somewhere in like the united states no
but it wasn't like the officer's fault
some like people called no i get i get
why but i'm just saying it's kind of
like if uh all of a sudden uh somebody
said hey i think that uh i was walking
by somebody's uh apartment or house or
whatever and i saw that there's a lion
in there and you get there's a stuffed
animal but you would expect that to
happen again somewhere in america where
people were like i don't know like i've
seen one line in my entire life whatever
but do we do we know where this is in
kenya
you know if there's you said there was
wildlife officers yeah yeah
okay so why does it matter where does it
say where is it near like a zoo is it
near any sort of like jungle air like i
don't know but what is the context
contained avocado seedlings i wonder if
the bag was meant to scare away like
rodents and those squirrels and those
like gophers that try to eat no
no
like the difference would be like if
somebody was like i see a lion and it's
in like miami i'd like ah it's probably
not a lion but if let's say let's say
that i was i don't know uh in montana
and they're like i saw a lion i'd be
like oh [ __ ] i'm going out i'm not going
outside i'm out well um it's all about
knowing what i'm i'm pointing to
questions oh what um
well we're not questioning we're not
there yet we're not there okay so
anything else to say about the lion no
i'm chilled the lion
you know i uh
honestly when we're walking in miami i'm
like i get scared of leaves some a leaf
nah do you want to know do you want to
know what the funniest thing in all of
miami no no no you wanna know the
funniest thing in miami is
the robots
oh yes the robots i got little little
flags on them and they'd be going around
they stop
and like look robots obviously aren't
human i don't have sentiment was it
sentiment beings sentient sentient
beings whatever uh but you look at it
and you're like why are you looking at
me and it's looking at you and then
you're like okay which way you going and
then it's like oh which way are you
going and then you're like am i talking
to a robot and then the robot doesn't
talk back and you're staring at it and
it's like a whole situation i don't know
i always feel bad for the robots because
all these people are like rushing by and
the robot just wants to get across the
street it has no feelings it has no
brain it doesn't have a heart it doesn't
have a conscious they don't have a soul
it's not going to heaven or hell it's
literally a piece of machine that's
going to get broken up at some point in
the future and tossed in the dumpster
yeah i'm just saying
that's very similar to a human being
yeah but like if you but if you see the
robot and it's like they got it's like
for food delivery and stuff and they got
little things i don't know like a box on
wheels
and then obviously they have like
sensors so if it sees people coming or
see like whatever uh it stops and when
it stops the first time you see it you
stop
and then you realize like i'm
interacting with a robot here and uh it
gets real weird
you don't feel that way no i just like
it it's called um what is it called um
when you like think that moving objects
are lifelike
you know what i'm saying like the roomba
like you you treat it like a pet you
know
what is it called
no you know what i mean
i don't know but do you want to ask a
lunch money yes okay okay so i actually
have a question but do we want to go
with the people what is the question
here first the question is
[Music]
what's the point of injecting all that
liquidity and
in stopping the market from crashing if
you're just gonna go ahead and crash the
market later that's my question too like
i'm so curious about that why
pump the market when you're just gonna
take it away
well there's two things that are
important to understand the first is uh
this all started in march of 2020
because there was a liquidity crisis
and a liquidity crisis there's no
liquidity in the market a great example
would be yo i want to use the pool but
there's no water in the pool so what do
you do you start pouring water into the
pool ah sweet that first one there's a
little bit of water i could go in the
pool i could chill out there's a little
bit more water i can go in the pool i
can chill out then there's even more
water i can go in the pool i can chill
out but at some point if you keep
filling up the pool the water starts to
overflow from the pool oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
we're creating a tsunami
and then you're like maybe we shouldn't
have so much water in the pool so you
start to contract the amount of water in
the pool now your goal
is to end up with the pool filled
but not overfilled and not under filled
it's like what they call it the uh uh
the bears
and the porridge
just right wait but i think that's the
three
uh golden bear what was it what was the
story the three golden bears three bears
that's what i call them i don't know i
call them bears so there's bears that's
right everyone knows the story the woman
comes she got the porridge she got too
hot too cold and just right that's what
they're trying to do they're trying to
do the just right of the pool now the
problem is
obviously
they think they're scientists but
they're not so what do they do they
goldilocks by the way they pour they
pour a bunch of water in it starts
overflowing they're like okay let's
contract but when they go to contract
they end up pulling too much water out
and there's not enough water in the
pools and they've got to go back to
filling it back up it's like a whole
game it's like not enough water too much
water not enough water too much water
not enough water too much water oh good
times bad times good times bad times
good times bad times and the whole thing
is that you literally have people
standing there and you know what they're
doing they're just like
and they don't even see what they're
doing they're literally not even paying
attention they're asleep at the wheel
they've lost all control all they know
is fill up the pool this is good and
they close their eyes and like two years
later like oh the pool's overfilled
let's take out some of the liquidity
and they close their eyes and they're
gonna come back in like 12 months and be
like oh my god there's no water in the
pool fill it back up like
and they're gonna do it for two more
years like it's a whole game they've
literally been doing this for decades
now and it's nonsense anthony just
showed you what happens when he tries to
fill a pool
so uh it's not the three golden bears
it's goldilocks and then it's not
whatever i said earlier it's an
anthropo
anthropomorphized
that's what i was trying to say you know
when you see like how he like i think
you're still trying to say it no okay
and then
and then what was the other thing
next question
oh okay uh somebody here asked
how did you propose
but listen i don't need to be talking
about that i did it on a bridge in new
york called me a bridge boy
[Applause]
i did
fax i thought i was going to a
networking event
right into a relationship or a blazer
okay you look very professional so did i
with my jeans with holes in them
all right so next question i don't know
hold on hold on hold on
are there questions yeah and people said
and she said yes
the best bridge boys show that's how we
gonna rename the show
somebody said question get money get
paid do you remember when i said that
yes i remember and then they think i'm
funny because i said it looks like
you're still trying to pronounce it
you got a about 30 seconds and then i
got other things
right
um
yeah i don't see more questions guys
help help help
no questions non-zero literally zero
hold on city boys up somebody's gonna
come through
oh congratulations jeff he has a
three-month-old boy oh nice
all right anything else anything else
anything else can we buy a horse named
bitcoin no
people want me to talk about do quan
here's uh here's the whole deal is every
single person is acting like they know
what the conclusion of this is
dokwan bought three billion dollars
worth of bitcoin there are now people
who are trying to break the peg
that rumors rumors rumors rumors rumors
citadel
and others are trying to break the peg
on ust i don't know if that's true or
not
i don't want to get into it
but
if you look and go back
tether stable coin peg
breaking
if i remember correctly
i have to go back i believe at one point
uh
yeah back in 2018 here's a little fact
for you for those of you that weren't
around
headline
crypto chaos as tether usdt stablecoin
breaks its peg dollar price
did any of you all who have it weren't
around 2018 did that stop y'all from
using tether
once they got back to the peg
so this nonsense this fear this fud all
this craziness there's a lot of people
yelling and screaming about the peg
95 of them can't describe to you how the
peg works nor how the peg got broken or
could the peg go back in place etc
95
of people
are just completely full of [ __ ] when it
comes to peg that's okay by the way i'm
not an expert in the peg either so
that's why i'm not you don't see me out
here tweeting saying oh the peg's gonna
break or the peg's not gonna break or
whatever
we need people to experiment
and there's always risk i did a whole
podcast episode including what i asked
what are the risks what are the pros why
are you doing this how does it work etc
and
naturally
as soon as this starts to happen people
start yelling and screaming and going
absolutely
crazy
but ultimately we don't know yet what
the answer is going to be if let's say
it is hypothetical
the peg broke yesterday
if all of a sudden three weeks from now
they go back to a peg
and it's now a peg that sticks
usdt
is that bad or is it not
should people be yelling and screaming
about it are they overreacting are they
under reacting nobody knows you we don't
know what the future holds
and so that's why
you see me sitting here saying
as i said before if dokwan is successful
in creating a stable coin backed by
bitcoin he would create a playbook on
how to do it
let's see if he's successful or not we
don't know yet we don't know yet
and so the peg broke
but the peg on tether broke before the
peg on many other stable coins broke
before
we don't know what the future holds
everyone else
needs to chill out because
the problem is
this is not a zero-sum game
and that's the number one thing that
just upsets me about this entire
ecosystem
is that
so many people believe
for my thing to win
your thing has to lose
it's not how the world works that's what
you told me when we played chess well
because you lost
it
is not a zero-sum game
whether ust works or doesn't work
has
zero
impact on whether bitcoin works or not
zero
bitcoin does not care about the ust peg
bitcoin does not care about tara bitcoin
does not care about luna and i think
dokwan will be the first person to say
bitcoin does not care about dokwan but
bitcoin also doesn't give a [ __ ] about
me or you or anyone else
bitcoin does exactly what it was
designed to do it will produce block
after block after block after block of
transactions and it will continue to do
so and it won't stop
it's that simple not simple and not
complicated we're out of time
all right i appreciate you coming on
thank you bye guys